hello everyone and welcome to a very
nice blitz game some of you have
requested it it's again between Magnus
Carlsen an international master Laurence
Trent I believe in neither of them needs
any introduction but it's it's a it's
really an interesting game as it
features the Norwegian defence but
Magnus Carlsen world champion so I'm
sure you're gonna enjoy it before we
check out the game I would just like to
invite everyone to check out a very nice
chest comedy video it's in French so
that could be a problem for you but if
you speak French I'm sure you're gonna
enjoy it and I've seen it I don't speak
French but if we do you know do share
with me who was it funny it's by Allure
Iran not sure if I pronounced that
correctly but I've met I met both Henry
and Kevin when I was in London during
the World Chess Championship match and
we spoke a few words in the street and I
asked if they were they were considering
making a chess video and they said yeah
it will be released in March and it's
March they released it so the first
thing in the description below will be a
link to the comedy video do do check it
out and you know share your comments
getting back to this game it's Lawrence
strange like we said versus Magnus
Carlsen Lawrence opens with E 4 we have
G 6 by Carlsen we have d4 and Knight to
f6 this is it this is where Carlsen goes
for the Norwegian defence where he is
inviting Lawrence to go for a5 and well
- let's say Knight h5 and then black
will try to attack White's
advanced bones it's a what is better
here of course but black is black is
asking why to prove that white is better
here and Lawrence is not interested this
is why Lawrence plays Knight to c3 and
here is the moment where call us across
and called him a chicken and as the
quote above the board says the lack of
cojones is astounding and quite
disappointing as Carson was expecting
this 'if I've idea from white I don't
know if I've mentioned it the the the
game was played it's a five-minute blitz
game it was playing on chest 24 calls
and had a blitz banter and now we have
defiled by Carlsen just he captures
Knight captures and now Bishop to c4
here Acosta mentioned that black doesn't
really have anything to worry about
anymore as white didn't go for the main
line but that white is perfectly fine
here white also has nothing to worry
about
nice to be six getting the night out of
the way also pressuring the LightSquared
Bishop to b3 and now just Bishop to g7
with a double attack against the d4 pawn
Knight G to e2 defending and now comes
Knight to c6 with a triple attack
against the pawn and Bishop to e3
defending and nice to a5 as white
already played twice with the lights
we're a bunch of black also is allowed
to play twice with the knight not not
considered a loss of a tempo as you are
pressuring the bishop but also you are
considering Knight c4 and going after
the undefended b2 pawn and a c4 is an
excellent square for the knight
if white wants to eliminate your knight
white will have to give up the bishop
pair we have castles by sorry castles by
trent castles by carlson and now trend
goes for d5 and here Carlsen immediately
seizes the initiative with Knight B to C
for breaking the defense of this pawn as
you see the bishop is no longer guarding
at pressuring b2 pressuring the bishop
on e3 so at least if nothing Carlson
will win the bishop pair and here
Crossan didn't mention that white could
go for Bishop b4 and try to go for this
pawn sacrifice but after let's say
Knight captures Queen attacks knight
Knight goes back now you can capture
capture and go Queen f4 with a double
attack against the night here the knight
can retreat to d6 and we have it's an
interesting position where black would
be a pawn cousin obviously was was
didn't have a problem with with facing
this line but Lawrence goes Bishop back
to see one just retreating with the
bishop defending this pawn and here we
have E 6 by Carlsen captures is possible
if captures Bishop would capture and
then if Queen captures rook can capture
this is what Carlson is hoping for but
here Lawrence goes Queen to d3 and now
across and just recapture Sun d5 so here
you have to play another move with the
Queen Queen captures was played you can
capture with the night because Bishop 2f
I would then be very strong for black so
here Queen captures on d5 was played
with Bishop to e6 Queen captures rook
captures not that hook and Carson
mentioned that he should have captured
with that rook but he decides to go for
this rook instead and I look to be one
protecting the b2
one of the dark square bishop can move
and also if the knight moves the bishop
will not be able to capture it but now
we have nice capture Sun b3 ache after
Sun b3 and not night to be do the rooks
are now both under attack so you do have
to capture tonight Bishop captures and
now just through capture son d2 and here
Carlson has not only the bishop pair but
Lawrence remains in Bishop lists he only
has two knights and the game is played
on both sides of the board it's a very
open position so black does have the
advantage and here we have looked to d1
you can't save the point with rook to
see one Bishop to F I would just pick it
up so that that's not not really an
option and you can go attacking bonds or
something as the Knights are protecting
themselves basically
so after this rook after sandy -
Lawrence tried rook to d1 and now cross
and did grab the pawn
we have night the d4 now Bishop captures
rook captures and now if Bishop captures
here and then Lawrence thought of rook
to be four with an idea of capturing
either the bishop or the Ponzo after the
bishop moves you could maybe start
picking up the points on the Queen side
so here instead of going immediately
after the point first c5 protecting the
be Foursquare while also forcing the
rook to move you can go here you can go
here the bishop is covering that so Luke
- a force plate going after the a
7-point and now a six we have looked to
any five and now defending this pawn
rook the c8 and here now there's really
nothing to do cross and we'll grab the
b3 pawn so Lauren's just defends it rook
to a3 and now here feel free to pause
the video you're up upon your having a
very nice game
feel free to pause the video and try to
find how to continue the game for black
it's a very nice idea so I'll give you a
couple of seconds as you roll for those
of you who were able to do it
congratulations you are an excellent
finder of nice ideas and for those of
you who just want to enjoy show rook to
d8 now there are no dangerous of losing
any pawns on the Queen side and rook the
d2 is a threat you don't really have any
any good ways of preventing that so here
we have h3 by Laurence making some
breathing room for the king but
it doesn't really help white all that
much across and just goes rook to d2
with Knight to e4 attacks the rook and
also defends DF to pawn and here just
rook to e2 and it was in this position
that the Lauren strange resigned the
game across and even mentions in the
video that you should resign even though
you have more time so Carlsen can play
some more games against other players
here you have to move the knight there's
really no other way you could protect it
to put something like f3 but then you
just lose the pawn here so the the the
best line for white would be Knight f6
check King attacks night-night checks
King attacks night and now Knight to c7
allowing this loss of a pawn so after
Luke captures you will capture the
bishop with Czech pawn captures and now
rook F 1 you will be able to you know
prevent further pawn grabbing on the
king sent by black but after black just
trades here goes king b7 black is up 2
points now with a completely winning
endgame white even has a doubled beep on
so it's it's not gonna be much of a
challenge so I have to look to e2 by
Carlsen Lauren strange resigned the game
and a very nice victory for Magnus in
this in this chess 24 blue it's been a
brawl so there we have it I do hope you
enjoyed it
Laurens most likely didn't but yeah yeah
like I said do check out the video by
Laura Jean once again no idea if I
pronounced that correctly and they do
share I'm very much interested for those
of you who understand French properly is
it a very nice funny video and yeah I
would like to thank Keaton sunrise at
our Scarpia Scott max Corey Gina
Santiago and Raymond young for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it
as usual you can check - in my previous
video so you're think all for watching
and I will see you soon later today I'm
gonna upload well we are continuing the
Capablanca saga basically I think you'll
have an excellent rest of your day and I
will see you soon